if you have a problem with your thyroid
gland your doctor may recommend a
thyroidectomy
your thyroid gland is located over your
larynx or voice box it wraps around your
trachea or windpipe
your thyroid produces a hormone called
thyroid hormone and secretes it directly
into your bloodstream
your body uses thyroid hormone to
increase your energy and raise your body
temperature when necessary for example
these effects help offset the heat your
body loses when exposed to cold weather
your doctor may recommend a
thyroidectomy if you have certain
thyroid cancers
an enlargement of the gland called a
goiter
benign nodules
cysts
or an overactive thyroid
before your procedure an intravenous
line will be started you may be given
antibiotics through the IV to decrease
your chance of infection you will be
given general anesthesia a breathing
tube will be inserted through your mouth
and down your throat to help you breathe
during the operation
to begin your surgeon will make a small
horizontal incision in your neck
depending on the reason for your surgery
your surgeon will remove one lobe of
your thyroid or the entire gland
your surgeon may put a surgical drain in
your incision to remove excess fluid the
drain will remain there for a day or two
at the end of your procedure the
incision will be closed with stitches
staples surgical glue or closure tape
dressings
after your procedure your breathing tube
will be removed and you will be taken to
the recovery area for monitoring your
surgeon may check your larynx for injury
you'll be given pain medication as
needed you may continue to receive
antibiotics through your IV
most patients are released from the
hospital one or two days after the
procedure your doctor may prescribe
calcium supplements if your entire
thyroid is removed you will take daily
thyroid hormone replacement medication